[Music]  that's right the polling sentences have  never ever been uttered before in human  history  this thing's gonna run Sochi smooth if  you want to get us a wedding gift we're  registered at RadioShack more Hamburger  Helper your majesty  I'm a vegetarian so I won't have any  questions about the menu set bro want to  practice butterfly kisses why can't  every clothing store have a DJ this good  I can't stop thinking about Delaware  another night of fighting off the ladies  at medieval times any chance you're  selling your PT Cruiser I'd like to fix  up that carnival worker with my sister I  like Paris but it's no Anaheim hey is  that the theme from Seinfeld I lost my  virginity to that song  do you know if these butt plugs are made  in America  [Music]  [Applause]